421 days ago,
Putin thought
he could overthrow
the Ukrainian government,
thought he could fracture nato
as he launched
an unprovoked war of aggression
with hundreds of thousands
of Russian forces
crossing the border and multiple
avenues of approach. He was wrong.
Ukraine's spirit remains unbroken.
There are now 31 members of Naito
and Naito is even stronger
and united
in the face of Russia's aggression
and its attack on the rules based order.
The United States
and the members of this Contact
Group remain committed
to supporting Ukraine
as a fight for freedom
against Russia's illegal
and unprovoked invasion.
To date,
the United States has committed
more than $35 billion
in military assistance,
including over 2 million tank
and artillery rounds, tens of thousands
of anti-armor
weapons systems,
air defense systems
and other forms of munitions,
hundreds of tanks
and armored vehicles
precision aerial munitions and
counter U.S. capabilities.
In addition,
there's about
2500 Ukrainian soldiers
conducting training right now.
In Germany.
Another 8800, almost 9000,
have completed training
and have returned to Ukraine,
and there are 65 Ukrainians
that completed training on Patriot
missile systems just recently
since the early phases of this war.
And for every month since,
the United States has provided Ukraine
with the capabilities to defend itself
and in conjunction
with our allies and partners,
we have delivered.
This coalition will continue
to provide vital training
and additional capabilities
for air defense and maneuver
to enable Ukraine's ongoing fight,
air defense, munitions
air defense capabilities, tank munitions,
armored vehicle
capabilities, artillery, ammunition,
artillery tubes and rockets
and spare parts remain critical
as Ukraine protects its cities and expels
the Russian menace from its territory.
Our countries and the
countries of Europe
have pledged
that Ukraine will have the capabilities
it needs to execute their missions
on their own timeline.
And we have pledged that support
for as long as it takes,
as the Secretary just said.
This week,
the United States announced
our latest security assistance package
as part of our ongoing commitment
to Ukraine.
As we stand here today.
The Ukrainian military
continues to perform very well
intense fighting in and around.
Baku continues
and has for several months.
Russia is expanding significant manpower
for very little gain
Russia is intensifying
indiscriminate shelling
and vigor in other cities
and urban areas.
And Russia
continues to pay severely
for its war of choice.
Unlike Ukrainian forces
who are highly motivated
to fight for their country,
to fight for their freedom,
their democracy and their way of life,
The Russian lack and leadership
they lack will.
The morale is poor
and their discipline is eroding.
Russia has resorted
to tightening conscription laws
as they
indiscriminately feed their citizens
into the chaos of war.
And so far,
they've been quite ineffective
in the coordination
or direction of combined arms
maneuver on the battlefield.
Over the past year, Russia's
temporary territorial gains
have come with enormous losses.
Hundreds of thousands of Russians
have fled their country.
In addition to the casualties,
they are trying to avoid fighting
in Putin's war.
Russia continues
to fail in achieving its
strategic objectives.
They failed to seize Kiev.
They failed to topple
the Ukrainian government.
And they failed to fracture NATO's
In fact, they've done just the opposite
Kiev stance.
The people of Ukraine are emboldened
and NATO's has never been stronger
As President Biden and Secretary
Austin have repeatedly said,
the United States remains committed
for as long as it takes.
Thank you.
And I look forward to your questions.
My question is going to both fighter
jets.
Ukraine said that they need more fighter
jets. Poland has just delivered mix.
Did you talk about fighter jets
and how helpful
could they be for Ukraine?
Right now
with what we all believe
is what Ukraine needs
most urgently is ground
based air defense capability.
That is what has enabled them to prevent
the Russian air forces
from having a meaningful,
meaningful impact in this fight.
And so you've heard us say that
for the last several months.
We will continue to say that because
that is what is is most important
in the current
in the future fight the immediate future.
We have to make sure that the Ukrainians
have the ability to
protect their infrastructure,
protect their citizens,
but also protect troops
that the troops are maneuvering.
So we we continue to engage our partners
and in allies and emphasize that
we need to do everything we can
to ensure that Ukraine has adequate
air defense, ground
based air defense capability.
And I have to applaud
the work that our partners are doing
where possible.
They're stepping up to the plate.
I believe that that we can still do more.
And I'm asking them to do more.
And I believe that they will respond.
First of all, those are policy questions.
They'll be made by political leaders.
But from a military perspective, the task
is to control the airspace.
How you control
that airspace can be done
in many, many different ways,
the most cost effective, efficient
and way to do that right now for Ukraine.
And the fastest way to do that for
Ukraine is through air defense.
They've been doing it for
over a year now.
They've been denying the airspace
to effective Russian use.
The Russians have been flying
some sorties
into Ukraine,
but limited amounts of sorties over
Russian occupied Ukraine.
The Russians have not done
battlefield air interdiction
deep into Ukraine territory
except through missiles and rockets
that have been fired from over
Russian territory.
Why is that done? By the Russians?
Because the Ukraine is shooting
Russian aircraft down.
So the Russians are cautious
to come into Ukraine
because of the effective
use of the Ukrainian air defense system.
That is the most critical thing right now
is that air defense system
to make sure that it is
robust, it's rigorous, it's deep,
and it's layered from high altitude, mid
altitude to low altitude
and from short range, mid
range to long range.
And the frontline
forces, the Ukrainian frontline
forces need to be protected.
That's the most important
critical military task right now.
That was the theme of this entire day.
Was air
defense, air defense, air defense
to make sure that
Ukraine can defend its airspace
in terms of the aircraft themselves.
There's a long lead time for
for training of pilots, etc.
And the Russians
have a significant amount of air power
and to take the Ukrainian air force
from where it is today
and to build it up to match the Russian
Air Force,
that's a significant level of effort
by lots of countries.
And those policy choices
may or may not be made down the road.
And we'll see where that goes.
But right now,
the immediate need is Air Defense
Secretary Austin,
our contact group members
working to speed up
deliveries of military supplies,
especially key items
such as artillery rounds
ahead of Ukraine's counteroffensive.
And does Ukraine have the items
it needs for that offensive?
And Chairman Milley,
do you think the Abrams tanks
will have a significant impact
once they arrive on the battlefield
in Ukraine?
The U.S.
has previously expressed concerns
about logistics
and sustainment for the tanks.
Have those concerns
been sufficiently addressed? Thank you.
So several
months ago, as we we set out to plan,
as our people
set out the plan with Ukrainian partners,
we outlined the parameters for
potential operations and we designed
the support that would be required
to to support those operations.
And we laid that out in detail.
And we that that set us on a path
to generate combat
power, combat capability.
You've heard us talk about the
the combat platforms,
the tanks, the Bradleys,
the Stryker, the striker's, Martyr's CB.
Ninety's
in all of this,
the sustainment that goes along with that
in all of the munitions required
to to be successful.
As you just heard
both what the chairman and I said
this was this was really difficult work
but we have met our initial goals
to provide
what's required to to get started.
And we will.
And we know
that combat is dynamic complex.
And so we understand
that we're going to have to continue
to sustain Ukraine's efforts
going forward.
When the
fight starts and
long after the fight continues.
So on the M1 tank,
you know,
I'm biased,
but I think the M1 tanks, the best
tank in the world,
there are all the tanks
that are quite good leopards,
for example, being provided as well.
But I do think the M1 tank when it is
delivered, will make a difference.
Now, let me distinguish between
in a couple of weeks,
you're got to get training tanks.
Those aren't quite combat capable
and they'll be used to train the crews
on how to shoot,
maneuver and maintain these tanks.
And that'll be part
of the sustainment package
to get them trained up
as the other tanks
are being refurbished in order
to accelerate their delivery.
But when they do get here
and those crews are trained
and they're using a combined arm maneuver
tactic
in combination with mech infantry,
the Bradleys, they'll be very effective.
But I would also caution
there's no silver bullet in war.
It's a it's a war.
The outcomes of battles and wars
are the function of many, many variables
And in this case,
you would have to make sure
that your tanks are used
in combined arms with mechanized
infantry, artillery.
All of that is synchronized
with dismounted forces, etc.
So there is no silver bullet
in this case.
But I do think
the M1 tank one is delivered
and it reaches its operational capability
that it will be very effective
on the battlefield